everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're in the
final round of our coverage the 2018
Canada's tournament winner of this
tournament will go on to face Magnus
Carlsen in November for the World
Championship and we have a close race we
have Fabiano Caruana
coming into the last round with a small
lead half a point over a couple
competitors and so he really needs a
strong performance here if he were to
draw and then a couple other players
were to win
Fabiana could see himself on the outside
looking in we have tie breakers with
Sergei cardiac in cardiac and would
actually win that so a half a point
behind if Carr yakin who won this thing
two years ago were to win and let's say
Cara wanna only tied his game then
karyakin would be the champion if for
some reason Cara Juana did lose his game
then all would take is a draw from
cardiac can we also still have shot gear
in the mix as well as Ling Dean both of
those players have an opportunity to win
this tournament all comes down to what's
gonna happen with Fabiano Cara Juana and
in this match that's what we're gonna be
looking at so Alexander glueck is
playing the white pieces fellow
countryman of Sergey Kuryakin so I'm
sure they had a little prep game for and
said hey if you could do me a solid and
beats Fabiano that would be very very
helpful so he's gonna be playing the
white pieces and then Fabiano the
American who has a slight lead coming
into the final round will be playing the
black pieces this trick starts out with
pawn to e4 pawn e5 Knight f3 and the
Knight to f6 this is the petrov defense
something we haven't seen too often in
previous tournaments but Fabiano seems
to really like this defense you play 14
rounds in this tournament seven is white
seven is black and you don't always get
an opportunity to play the pitcher off
because your opponent's gonna need to be
playing pawn to e4 to start with a lot
of players like to play pawn to d4 but
of the 7 games Fabiano's played in this
tournament as black four of them have
been the petrel defense so something
that he is familiar with and prepared
for specifically for this tournament now
we see pawn to d4 usually the main line
has been nice
- II five pawn to d6 nine back here to
f3 and then after Knight takes on e4
then there's gonna be some variation we
could just see the pawn moving forward
here Knight to c3 has been fairly common
but in this particular game we see the
Stein inspiration that is pawn to d4
Black has options could take either pawn
Knight to e4 is valid pawn takes on d4
both of those are completely fine
we have Fabiano deciding to take with
this night here on e4 pawn recaptures
and you know from here the main line
would be Bishop to d3 just attacking the
knight right here but decided to go
ahead and take here on e5 pawn down here
to d5 Knight to d2 and after the knight
takes we have recapture here with Bishop
takes on d2 and then a seven getting
read the castle on the King side if Abby
wants to bishop here to d3 same thing
getting away the castle on the King side
if he wants to pawn to c5 pawn up here
to c3 a lot of different variations that
white can go to from here could push
even further if you want to castle on
the King side decided to go ahead and
play pawn up here to c3 now Knight to c6
just development move of the minor
pieces towards the center of the board
casts on the King side Bishop down here
to g4 pinning down this Knight to the
Queen on a d1 rook here to e1 Queen to a
d7
this does open up the opportunity for
black to castle on the Queen side but I
I would guess that Fabiano knowing that
the worst case is he needs to draw this
thing did not have as good experience
castling on the Queen side with a lot of
air in front of his King so I still
think that with this Queen here to d7
he's just getting that involved in that
the game not necessarily looking to
castle on the Queen side paneer to h3
forcing the bishop come back here to h5
Bishop up here to f4 giving it more
involvement to the game protecting this
pawn this nights here on c6 is attacking
it yes this Knight here on F
is defending it but it since it is being
pinned down by this bishop here on h5 do
you want to add another layer of
protection so Bishop up here to f4 and
now Queen to e6 adding another attacker
on the square here on e5 why plays pawn
to a3 castle on the King side pawn up
here to b4 pawn to a6 just solidifying
this grid here on a g5 Bishop comes back
here to g3 still controlling this long
dark square diagonal as well as the pawn
on e5 and then pawn to b6 so solid
opening from both sides all things look
fairly equal they had the same amount of
material same type of material as well
and no side has a clear advantage as far
as how they are going to attack knight
here to d4 is where Alexander gets
pretty creative as far as how he wants
to continue and this is a fairly good
move but something he did not have to
make if you look at it immediately it
looks kind of weird cuz just a pawn
could take it but you have to also have
to keep in mind that you know if the
pawn takes here on d4 that Knights was
being pinned down so all of a sudden
there is an attack going on with this
Queen here on d1 and this bishop up here
in h5 so the Queen could take a pawn to
g6 if you want to attack that the Queen
gobble up this material here on h6 if
you want so you can now gain material on
c3 and starting to push forward with a
passed pawn but black really doesn't
want to have to deal with this Queen
over here on the King side of the board
so instead Fabiana decides yeah I don't
want to worry about your Queen I want to
simplify things again he wants to make
sure that worst case he does get a draw
in this game so Bishop down here to a d1
Knight takes the Queen definitely want
to take the Queen back pawn takes here
on e6 and then the rook takes oh this is
a fine trade for both sides does
simplify the game for both sides and
then Fabi plays pawn to see
and this pushes forward with his ponds
gets him some space especially when you
start to trade down material you want to
really push your advantage with your
ponds and that's what Fabiano looks to
do here one thing that you will notice
is that alexander gurko has the bishop
pair so if he can open up the board his
bishops can reign supreme
Fabiana wants to make sure that he still
has pawns in the center so these bishops
can't do as much damage and then just
try to continue to push solidify his
pawn chain with moves like pawn to b5
pawn to a6 and then just have this
dark-squared bishop control as many
squares as possible
Bishop down here to a c2 pawn to b5 punt
up here to a4 says yeah that's fine I'll
play pawn a6 if you want to exchange
that's fine as well pawn here to f3 not
as worried about pushing pawns in front
of the King once the Queen's come off
the board here Bishop down here to a g5
wasn't doing too much back here as we
talked about this is a closed position
with all these pawns
so want to limit some of the squares of
your opponent can go to with Bishop here
to g5 Bishop down here to f2 bishop down
here f4 Bishop c5 attacking of the rook
rook to a CH and then Bishop here to a
d6 so the bishop came down here to f4
attacking the pawn on e5 goodness you
did a good job nuvaring his bishop
around the clock and now does have a
outpost here on d6 which is a great
square
you know this pawn is being attacked by
the bishop and the knight here but is
defended by his own bishop and rook here
on e1 if I plays Bishop to g3
rook here to e2 just getting it off
these dark squares since it's being
attacked pawn to g5 so Fabiana is
starting to push on the King side King
here to f1 king f7 at Bishop here c7
attacking the rook rook over here to e8
Bishop down here to d6 rip C eights work
over here to a-1 and both sides are
pretty equal in material here rook 2
eight and then Bishop down here to be
one and it was about this point in the
game where the other opponents in the
tournament actually were drawing their
gains they were coming to a conclusion
and so it was apparent to Fabiano around
this time that all he needed it was a
draw and he would be victorious now a
lot of players would even just offer up
a draw to their opponents here not that
ignition would actually take that
because a lot can happen in this
position and what you know militia does
have the white pieces so he wants to
have his plan come to fruition whatever
that may be
but Fabiano continued to push for trying
to see what he could come up with this
game even as the black pieces but in
this position we started to realize that
Fabiano was only a draw away from
becoming the candidates tournament
champion and then going on to face
magnus carlsen rook down here to a d7
a rook to a3 this does open up the door
for the pond to start pushing forward
here on d4 so pawn to d4 pawn takes here
on a five who come back and say you know
why did he do this earlier you know when
the rook was here on d1 if it comes over
here to a1 if there was an immediate
push to d4 well you could see pawn takes
on b5 after the pawn recaptures pawn
takes and if the knight takes then rook
to a7 check and after the the King moves
here to g8 then Bishop to g6 this is
attacking this rook here on e8 and that
is an important piece to keep in mind as
we come back and say rook here to a a 1
and then Fabiano very wisely plays rook
to d8 so he calculated all this through
and said yes I want to be playing pawn
to d4 but I don't want to have to worry
about my opponent playing bishop up here
to g6 and then attack my rook so very
important as we now see bishop back here
to b1 rook to d7
here to a3 and now it makes sense why
Faviana waited in plays pawn to d4 cuz
we still see the exchange here on b5
after the pawn takes pawn recaptures now
Knight to d4 the rook can't come up here
to a7 as a tempo move to check the
opponents and now this Knight is
attacking the rook here on e2 after the
rook moves now here's the key move the
knight comes back here to c6 and now
both the knight and the pawn or the
knight is attacking the pawn as well as
the bishop here on g3 so a much better
position for Fabiano also has a passed
pawn here on c4 that he can start to
push forward good this shook plays a
bishop here to be for attacking of the
Knights
Bishop takes here on e5 Bishop takes
here and then the rook takes down here
on d6 I want to make sure that you
always capture correctly you want to
capture and not give up any other major
or minor pieces if you play a bad move
like rook takes on c6 then just the
bishops gonna take here on e5 White has
two rooks and a bishop that's gonna be a
pretty bad exchange even with this past
pawned just not something you want to do
so Fabi plays rook takes on d6 Bishop
takes here on b5 and then rook down here
to d1 so both sides are equal in
material but I would say that black has
the advantage is he has a pawn that's
more pushed off the board that his
opponent you can start to see his king
is further up the board
not by much I recognize but still
further up the board and he's already
started his attack on his opponent so
not the biggest advantage but black it
definitely has a slight advantage as we
are 37 moves into the game so King here
to e2 rook over here to g1 attacking the
pawn on g2 King to III just trying to
centralize the King also opening up for
the rook here on a2 to protect the pawn
here on g2 rook over here B 1 attacking
the past pawn a4 white rook to a7 check
King to f7 just centralizing that as
well
Bishop here to d7 Bishop
down f/4 check the King King comes back
here to youtube and then rook to d8 so a
Fabia continuing to push with his attack
now attacking the bishop here rook over
here to see to says yeah I have my rook
defending the bishops I'm not too
worried about it right now I want to
start to attack this past pawn right
here on c4 the rook takes on b4 Bishop
comes back here to c6 you can see that
black is now up a pawn in material and
he has the only passed pawn so things
are definitely looking good for black we
see pawn to c3 which is such a great
move if you look at it almost looks like
black can't continue to push I always
want to push your past pawns but it's
not clear how it can do that but if you
push this how is white really going to
take if we see rook ticking here on c3
this is going to be made because rook
down to D tube the King can't come to d3
or e3 because the both the rook and the
bishop play well together can't come
here to f2 or d1 because of the rook and
doesn't really matter where he goes from
here maybe King to f1 rook down here to
b1 be the same thing if it was on e 1 as
well the rooks gonna have to come down
to just save a move but it is going to
be checkmate so if we come back that
pawn can easily push for to c3 just
another thing that White has to worry
about another thing to note is that
Fabiano can keep it on c3 for awhile
until he's ready to push forward all the
way down he wants to keep it on a square
where this light squared bishop cannot
attack it and he's eventually gonna get
most of his material he has his king all
of his pawns bishop in both of his rooks
on dark squares that completely takes
out of the game this light squared
bishop so keep in mind as we're going
through how Fabiano is positioning all
his pieces both to help his other pieces
but then also to avoid any attack by
Alexander go to show exhibition rook
here to d7 we're clear c8 Fabiana says
yeah I like to use my pieces I'll go
ahead and start to attack yours bishop
down here to e4 it's a great outpost
it's not doing much more than just
stopping any threats that king our black
has pushing forward maybe King here to
f5
so pawn to h5 King up here to d3 rook
down to B to says yeah if you want to
take my rook now that's fine I'll just
go ahead and take back and that's gonna
be an easy victory for me King to e2
pawns who h4 rook down here it's a d1
King to e5 rook to a-1 so both sides
just maneuvering a little bit more and
we we thought for a while that Alexander
grishnack was going to resign this is
losing position especially at the
highest level there's no way to stop
this pawn you know now with the rook
here on d8 this is stop this King from
ever coming over to this D file so
that's taken out of the game and so
since there's no great way to stop this
black should have an easy path to
victory my guess is if Fabiana wanted to
extend his hand to goodness shook good
issue would probably actually take the
draw wouldn't change too much as far as
final standings but if you aren't a
losing position your opponent says do
you want to draw most high level players
are going to do that he may have
continued just to see what he could come
up with it would take a serious blunder
for Fabiano at this point to lose the
game but Fabiano never offered a draw
and he's one of a few players maybe him
and magnus carlsen would be the only
players that could extend the hand get a
draw and win the tournament and say yeah
i'm gonna go ahead and play on because i
have a winning position i want to see if
i can actually win this game now we see
rook to d1 we're over here to be a to
adding protection on the b file bishop
down here to d2 so this is a great
outpost the whole games about this setup
right here and so while the outposts
usually want to have in the center
control a lot of the board if lots not
going on the rest of the board you
really just want to control where the
action is that's what that Bishop does
rook up here to a6 attacking the pawn on
e6 sure rook over
here back to d8 rook to c6 attacking the
pawn rook down here to be 1 and then
King to f2 it doesn't do any good if
let's say white decides to take that
pawn cuz we're over here to eat 1 check
that the King moves and then just the
bishop is gonna take that rook maybe the
rook takes and then work over here to a
1 Black has the same amount of pawns but
he has two rooks against rook and a
bishop going into the endgame that's in
game that most you know high-level
players are gonna be able to do very
very easily Fabi being clearly one of
those players so King to f2 we're over
here to a 1 then rook down to a c4 rook
to d4 so just pressing his advantage
slowly and surely no way to really get
out of this from White's perspective
rook up here to c8 rook to b4 King over
here to e2 King to f4 and can eventually
get it to g3 no way to really do
anything with this light squared bishop
this rook here on c2 can't move and so
it really comes down to this rook on c8
and he can't really stop this king from
doing much at all so the King comes here
to f2 from stopping the King down to g3
rook down to b1 rook to f8 check King up
here to e5 which is completely fun
Bishop down here to DC rook to be to
King over here to e2 rook to e1 check
King comes back now says yeah you're
gonna have to exchange because I have
trapped your rook right here so there is
an exchange pawn takes and now the pond
just waits for his opportunity to come
over here and promote to something you
know you promote to a queen your
opponent has to take that then you just
have traded a bishop for a pawn that's
not something you want to do in the in
game so the rook has to swing over here
to b8 and White's material is just
sitting there having to protect where
black can start to attack on the King
side the board too many weaknesses for
white to deal with Bishop here to c3 but
you have to e4 Bishop d5 King to e2 this
does open up the door for the King to
start getting involved into the action
rook down here to b4 pawn to e5 so
inhale all the material you can see for
black is on dark squares so really just
comes down to what is this rook gonna be
able to protect from white point-of-view
rook back here - b7 King - g3 and now
attacking you know this square here on
g2 the King can't come back here to f1
because of the rook and in this position
white realized it's all gonna fall apart
can just start gobbling up all the
material there's no way to stop it and
so good ishik resigns Fabiano when he
didn't even need to gets the victory in
round 12 he loses the circuit karyakin
and it looked like it was not going to
be victorious similar to two years ago
he had in his grasp and then let it slip
away and this one he won the last two
games in the tournament even last one
would just need to draw he fought for
the victory and that's exactly what he
got as the black pieces so
congratulations to Fabiano Caruana
an American gonna be representing the
United States in the world championship
in November or something if Erika has
not had for over 20 years so that's
gonna be exciting for those players that
were rooting for Fabi this is a huge day
a huge day coming we're gonna have a -
20 something year olds facing off in the
tournament in November so excited for
that one we do have some months in
preparation many tournaments before that
we'll be covering but hopefully guys
enjoyed a fantastic Hannah's turn about
2018 one of the best tournaments I
remember covering for some time now so
thank you for everyone that watched
throughout all the coverage that I put
together and I look forward to seeing
you in the next tournament thanks again